hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game that really shows how how
easy chess is when you fully understand
that it's from yesterday's the knockout
phase of the chess ball masters the
quarterfinals magnus crossing versus
david tongiharo uh and this is game
three game one was won by magnus game
two was drawn and now magnus has a
chance to enter the game before the
match before even reaching game four he
has the white pieces
and this is what happened you guys will
enjoy this one as magnus opens with f4
he goes for the bird's opening uh sorry
about that uh in game one he opened with
the english so this is uh basically the
same only on the only on the king's side
so f4 and the d5 now is the
well the the standard way of uh
challenging the the bird's opening but
uh davin anton goes g6
and okay we have e4 magnus grabs the
center now we have d5 challenging the e4
pawn and d3 here magnus even offers um
davina anton to go uh for a queen trade
with the early captures captures and
queen captures and d1 this will ruin
carlson's ability to castle
but he's down in a match and you don't
really want to force an game against
magnus already on move three that's not
uh that's not wise so bishop to g7 we
have knight to f3 and now uh again you
could again go for this trade it's
perfectly possible but uh you know no
one wants to play playing in-game sorely
against magnus he would seem and we have
c5 and it is now as of move four that we
have a completely new game which is
which is pretty awesome bishop to e2
magnus continues development and knight
to c6 we have castles and pawn to e6 now
uh c3 and the knight g to e7 we have
bishop to e3 so just nicely developing
for both sides and b6 now preparing
bishop to b7 or maybe even bishop to a6
we have queen to c2 and bishop to a6 now
uh a4 by magnus
and now rook the c8 we have rook to d1
aligning the rook nicely with the queen
on the d file castles by david anton and
now comes knight to a3 and this is a a
bit of an overly ambitious um idea for
magnus he wants to get this knight over
to b5 but as you'll see it was necessary
to play bishop to f2 here uh because
once knight to a3 is played here david
anton plays the incredibly strong knight
to d4 this is the position i've chosen
from the thumbnail for the thumbnail uh
so the the one that um you guys have
seen when you when you decided to click
on this video now the idea is of course
the queen and the bishop are attacked
and you can't just move the queen
somewhere uh you're going to lose the
bishop and what happens if you capture
the knight with the pawn well then come
c captures on d4 the queen is attacked
and also the bishop on e3 is attacked
and that's why bishop to f2 was a
necessary idea to prevent this whole
knight to d4 business and once we play
some like queen bee 3d captures on e3
and you can see that the black is um
just all over the place the those
bishops slicing the entire board in half
the row controlling the c file uh very
very strong play by black so instead
magnus plays bishop captures on d4 but
even this isn't great as you have to
give up the bishop pair very early on so
c captures on d4 and now magnus plays c4
we have queen to c7 now again you cannot
uh capture or anything as the queen on
c2 would hang
so queen to d2 and now d captures an e4
we have d captures and rook f to d8 and
the david anton can be very happy with
himself uh he retains a better position
and he has a past the d-pawn and it's
not going to be easy to stop this pawn
bishop to d3 magnus blockades the pawn
now and here comes pawn to e5 now here
uh the uh absolute best way to treat
this position is bishop to b7 go after
the four pawn and then strike in the
center with f5 but after bishop to b7 uh
magnus uh sorry after e5 and magnus just
uh
well he just bounces right back in the
game uh he goes for knight to b5 now now
the queen is attacked so you can't just
play anything queen to b8 and now knight
captures on e5 we have bishop capture
spawn captures and now david anton
doesn't want to capture on e5 because
the a7 pawn hangs so first he plays
knight to c6 uh to go after the pawn but
now knight to d6 magnus goes after the
rook here so rook to c7 and now queen to
g5 and even though the position is
roughly equal
it's a very very unpleasant uh getting
all of this uh
pressure from magnus so here rook c to
d7 uh and now b4 of course magnus will
not pass up uh pass on on the
opportunity to execute b4 and it seems
like you could capture it because b5 is
coming uh but uh you would be in in uh
grave grave danger if you capture this
if you capture the b4 pawn then your
knight is no longer attacking the e5
pawn and the knight here just becomes
too strong look at all of the dark
squares in front in front of the black
king
knight f5 pretty much ends the game uh
there's not all that much you can do
let's say you trade the knight for
bishop we just capture we don't really
care what's your next move you're going
to play something let's say rook 8 you
want to add more control over the e7
square knight h6 check and once you move
the king knight to g4 now the knight is
coming to f6 also you're just guarding
this pawn also rook to f3 is coming rook
to rook to f1 is coming e6 is coming
there's no stopping this position let's
say you play something h5 we're going to
play knight to f6 and after let's say
rook e back to d8 we're gonna play queen
h6 king to e7 and now queen g5 threaten
all sorts of nasty discoveries so black
will have to run away and now of course
we just win back material captures
captures e6 and that's it rook is coming
to f1 it's just a game over here so
that's what happens if you capture the
b4 pawn of course that cannot be
uh played so the video goes for the e5
paul knight captures an e5 queen
captures as this removed the defender of
the knight on d6 with queen captures and
now rook captures on d6 and here it
seems like davina anton uh defended well
and there is nothing that magnus can do
however there is one move that pretty
much forces a terrible terrible end game
for black
you can win a pawn here it's not easy to
spot but i'm sure you guys can do it so
feel free to pause the video here and
gain the winning advantage while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding this
incredibly forcing line that wins the
pawn and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is pawn to c5
that's that's it we open up an attack
towards the bishop and the rook is now
uh
also attacked so what can you do here b
captures b captures and now rook the c6
of course we have to move the rook so
rook to c6 now we offer a queen trade
magnus goes for a queen trait captures
captures and now by trading queens
you've removed the defender of the d4
pawn now bishop captures an a6 uh rook
captures on a6 and rook captures on d4
by grabbing the spawn you are now up
upon and now you are pushing to win this
so rook to c6 we're gonna go after the
c6 spawn rook to c1 now comes rook beat
the c8 and just rook to d5 so now magnus
defends the pawn uh nicely and now it's
time to bring the king into the game so
both players start bringing their king
into the game king f8 king f2 king is
seven uh now g4 of course the g5 would
be would be a dream so of course h6 with
h4 by magnus and rook the b8 now trying
to infiltrate with with the rook here as
throwing some trouble uh but the g5 we
have h captures h captures and now first
king the e6 you could also
uh go for rook to b4 uh but then rook to
e5 might be might be very annoying so
first david anton uh handles this by
playing king to e6 and now king the e3
rook the b3 with chuck king to d4 and
now rook to b4 with check and here
magnus just plays rook to c4 he offers a
trade of rooks uh rook back to b1 and
now rook the e5 with check king d7 and
now king to d5 here king the c3 is a bit
more precise but this is rapid chess of
course you can't play play perfect moves
uh all the time
rook to d1 with check rook to d for
blocking and now rook captures on d4 we
have king captures and the rook the a6
going after this spawn and now it seems
like david anton will win his pawn back
and bounce back in the game but magnus
has something else to say about the
position and he just plays a5 and now uh
to david anton's horror if you capture
on a5 then c6 with check opens up a
discovery and you blunder your rook so
of course that cannot be played king the
d8 is played but now we even have king
to d5 now magnus willingly gives up the
a51 uh to win the d6 square for his king
so rook captures an a5 king to d6 now if
rook is six check then we're just going
to block with pawn to c6 so rook to b5
and now we have rook to e7 going after
this pawn in this pawn and that's it
you're now just going to lose the game
so the last attempt is rook captures and
c5 hoping to well hoping that if magnus
captures you you're you're just gonna
have a winning end game because of the
past a pawn but of course magnus just
captures on a7 uh we have rooked the c8
now defending against any rook to eight
check ideas uh rook captures on f7
there's just no defending this king
eight we have rook to f6 going after the
pawn rook the a8 and now you have to be
very careful you know when you're this
close to victory you cannot play a move
like rook captures because then rook a6
check blunders the rook so i hope none
of you were considering this so king e5
that's the cleanest way to do it rook to
a5 check king to f4 uh we have rook to
b5 and now just the rook captures and g6
king f7 we have rook to a6 and he was in
this position on move 54 that david
antony how resigned the game uh as there
is nothing more to be done here so for
those of you who like it when i finish
the games the game might continue
something like let's say rook b1 black
wants to be annoying and start checking
the white king we don't really care rook
f6 check we're going to move the king e5
now and after something like rook f1
check we're going to move the king
capturing is impossible we just connect
our pawns and then of course the king
and end game is winning rookie one check
king to d5 rook to g1 now going after
the pawn now even king to d6 now we can
give up the pawn because after this uh
we just move the rook we control the
entire f file and now we're just gonna
push our pawn to victory but we still
have to be careful rook g3
king the e7 you don't want to play a
move like e6 then black will have a
force to draw with rook to a3 but that's
um uh you know a theme for a different
video uh king to e7 and now the black
king really has no no good options if
you move the king rook g1 check and if
you just uh move move your king we can
advance the pawn finally king g7 we're
going to play rookie one king the g8 now
king the e8 the king g7 we're gonna put
the pawn to e7 and finally once the rook
moves we're gonna deliver this check uh
king to f6 and our king f8 and once uh
the pawn reaches the e8 square we will
have a queen and the black will then
finally resign so of course both of them
notice after rook day six oh sorry uh
after
uh yeah after rook day six uh uh david
tony resigned the game and that's it for
for this game and for this match so the
match ends before uh without game four
even being played magnus takes the win
and uh for those of you who don't know
how the other matches went you can see
that um anishigiri defeated aryan tari
uh pragananda defeated wei yi dingliran
defeated mamidarov and the magnus
carlsen defeated david anton all of the
matches ended with a score of two and a
half
uh or rather no uh anishigiri uh
arientari two and a half half uh huey
pregnant one and a half two and a half
months of dingler and one and a half two
and a half and carlsen davido turned two
and a half uh to have so here in the
semi-finals we will have anish versus
pragananda and the magnus vs ding so
those will be the games that we will be
covering today uh hope uh hope we're
gonna
enjoy some nice chess but until then
that's it for this video so once again i
hope you guys enjoyed it uh as you can
see uh there was that one moment where
david anton could have pushed for the
initiative but he uh gave up his
advantage and then he had an equal
position against magnus but that
uh you know especially with the uh
lower time controls is is
very rarely enough to hold the draw uh
so i would like to thank david kimura
adam simmons robert kiefer mark manor
and nagarjuna ponogoti for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
magnificent event
until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day